bruce said that to transcend
technique it has to punch it has a kick
you don't punch
it punches it kicks it elbows it knees
it head smashes all right it does
everything
it grapples it locks it chokes it
strangles
it was the transcending yourself
you don't know how you hit it hit it hit
it by itself without even unconscious
effort
that's what he's talking about the it so
he's transcending
the physical he told me once well i
don't know if it's true not he said that
he could see himself if there was a
person he's fighting
that he never fought the battle from
here he fought the battle from here
and he could see himself and the
opponent he says
i said let me get this straight now you
mean your opponent's here
and you're here and you're not here
watching this guy he says yes i'm
watching from here
so he had that saying and i think it's
in one of his sayings is
be like a wooden uh doll that has no
ego it just moved like a wooden dog
because you
move so he can absorb it uh
like you said you can observe things
better from a third person
of what creely like it's it's uh when i
train
uh fighters uh
i can understand why they couldn't see
the opening when they were sparring
right
and why they didn't cover this but when
you get in there
you can't see the opening you could see
it from the third person and that's
where bruce was saying he was seeing it
pretty good example when i played
football
uh if i made a good run
it was so effortless when you're up
there in the stadium
you you can see the openings where he
should have ran left and right but when
you're running with the ball
you can't see the opening sometimes
right your coach from the bench can see
it and your scout up there in the
stadium
can see where you should have ran left
or right or should you should have put
on a speed or should
you stop short and cut to the left or to
the right but when you're
in the heat of it you really can't see
it right
that's uh what he's saying that he sees
it from a third
person therefore he can see the openings
that's why a trainer has to tell
his boxer or his fighter when he comes
back to the corner
he says loop with the overhead he's
dropping his hands because
sometimes he's so occupied in trying to
defeat his opponent
he can't see it because he's not a he's
not a wooden doll
you have to be formless as he should
tell us
and that's like i think what he's trying
to say it it
does it because he's no longer in the
body